the jurogan experience it's
really interesting watching someone's
path when you know that they already did
it
that's there's something about that like
reading about kennison
like knowing that he already did it yeah
just to read the path
and how it all went yeah and it's
interesting too if you look at like you
know prince had a really good book
it was actually a collection of things
he'd written with somebody just before
uh that he passed but
you read the book and like it's
interesting because you're like you are
of course you know he's gonna be prince
one of the more talented people that may
ever
you know walk the planet and so you're
reading it and you're hearing him get
denied with demo tapes and hearing no
one's believing in him that he's a weird
kid and all that but you know that he's
prince
yeah you have like as you read the book
you kind of have a secret that like
you're unstoppable like this stuff
doesn't really matter what you're going
through in your high school and you're
like basketball and this person denied
and that person didn't want to be like
none of this
it's interesting but what's actually
most fascinating is you literally were
you were destined to be prince one way
or another
yeah this stuff is almost
inconsequential you're going to be
prince someday
well it is fascinating knowing that he
he did become prince but you kind of
feel the anxiety of the journey right
like when you're reading about someone
even though you know it is
inconsequential you are
there's no denying he became prince but
he didn't know that
well while it was all going down no
that's what's cool about it but it's fun
to read
you can read that and you can hear the
people who don't believe in them and you
can be you know like
we all have a i missed that one kind of
moment or i didn't see that but like
imagine me the guy who's like yeah you
know i had prince came into my i didn't
hear it
yeah i didn't hear it i
remember the exact moment i first
listened to prince
i was in an audi fox i had an audi fox
this is a little
shitty front wheel drive car i was
driving on the massachusetts turnpike
and i had a cassette that i just bought
and i just unwrapped it
and i popped it in the cassette player
and it was uh i listen
i'm going to be your lover i want to be
your lover that song and it was the one
where
you know the cassette where him it's
like he's got no shirt on and it's like
he's just staring at the camera and i
remember thinking like holy [ __ ]
like who is this guy yeah like this is
just different
yeah you know it's like he's singing in
a falsetto about being in love with a
girl and his
his voice is incredible oh you could be
that outrageous if you're gonna be
really good
yeah we get a lot of the other which is
people who are outrageous and they're
compensating for not really having much
to sing or say but like
right he had he was fully loaded he had
all of it well he
was that guy i mean that's who he was i
mean it was outrageous because he was an
honestly eccentric human being i mean
that
really was who he was an insanely
talented eccentric human being you know
i met him once actually
i met him with dean delray no way yeah
at a club out in uh
in new york maybe it's early 2000s
and i forgot what the club was was very
very it was crowded and somebody this is
a true story somebody come to me and
said
tapped me in the shoulder said you know
prince is here he wants you to come sit
down
and uh i seriously i heard i followed
and i thought i was gonna go sit with
prince william
that sounded more believable to me that
sounded like i
that i believed and then we went over
and it was obviously
prince roger from nelson yeah but it was
a really funny night i'm glad dean was
there too
um we sat in a booth it was princeton it
was his lawyer
bodyguard he had a lawyer slash
bodyguard that's what he was and he was
a very big guy we sat in a booth
and it's hard to imagine now that like
you know the guy he wasn't like being
swarmed with people in the sprints you
know but um
it the he it's it's awkward it's like
you know you're sitting four of us from
the booth just kind of like
you know i know what to say and it's
kind of loud so if he did if i did want
to really have a conversation it'd be
difficult but
the bodyguard kind of nudges me and he
says you know it's been 25 years since
uh
purple rain and i was like oh that's
awesome and then he
he's sitting next to me he goes excuse
me i said that's awesome
he goes what's awesome i go
the purple rain is 25 years old what a
great record he goes
great record i say yeah he goes well
tell him
he's pointing at prince so now i'm like
he's a
very large man is like nudging me and
i'm thinking that's amazing prince
he is he he cannot be insecure that
people don't love purple rain but i
leaned over and i said you know
purple rain like wow 25 years what a
great record and he kind of fanned
himself he's like oh well you think so
and like even prince needed to hear once
in a while that he was awesome
how weird is it this bodyguard those big
giant dude's like nudging you to tell
prince that he's awesome i feel like i
got set up
like he knew prince needed a compliment
maybe i'd be nervous that he would go of
course it's good [ __ ] yeah i was
nervous well it was awkward like
what is it it's like the night at the
rocks for you just kind of sit in the
booth just like
you know uh it is him it is prince right
it is and then like you know and so you
guys aren't really interacting
a little bit um not a lot i think he
just
he invited me just to come sit just
but it was also very it was very loud
but that wasn't the problem
i think he just you know i don't know
why i was asked to sit but he was very
nice he was you know
he's very very cool catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience